today we have something a little
different
dr jane goodall is going to tell you a
story
ready
let's begin
it starts as a whisper
a word on the air
it can't quite be heard but you know
that it's there
as gentle as sunlight as tenacious as
hell in its root to the heart it could
not but prevail
and the people looked up from their
day-to-day tasks their day-to-day jobs
and their day-to-day masks
they heard or they felt where the
whisper could lead and they looked with
eyes wide at what that might mean
[Music]
and once they could see it
they hadn't a chance
to resist the sweet song of the deep
spell it cast
but the feeling it brought them at first
glance
was pain
as they lifted their eyes on the land
they had claimed
since they saw at last as if raised from
a dream
they were almost alone in the land of
the sea
[Music]
but the trees had almost gone and the
bees had almost gone and the creatures
in their shells by the seas had almost
gone and the people felt sad as they saw
their new earth but they knew this was
it
one wild chance for rebirth
breaking new ground seeds rolling down
smell of the earth on your hands and
your brow
no time for sorrow
we're building tomorrow
the sound of things growing now keeps us
around
[Music]
as the wildness grows and the deep wood
grows
and the sense that the futures come to
meet you bros
there's no chance we can rest
we must do our best
this moment can lead us back home
that's our test
it starts as a whisper
a word on the air
it can't quite be heard but you know
that it's there
it then spoke like thunder
until we all moved and we could
and we did and it's done
she's renewed
[Music]
help turn the whisper into a raw by
sharing this poem today and subscribe to
our channel to learn about the latest
exciting efforts to curb global
emissions and regenerate our planet
you